-Guys, finally it is Tuesday.
It is time for "WePost."
Here we go.
-♪ WePost ♪
♪ WePost ♪
Welcome to "WePost."
This is where we
as a group decide something
we should post on socials.
I'm going to show you
five different posts.
We're all going
to vote on whether
you like each one or not.
You all have voting clickers
at your seats.
Yep. Hey, perfect.
Alright.
You can vote for all of them.
You can vote for none of them.
Whatever you want,
I just want you to have fun,
have a good time here.
Higgins, Roots.
You have clickers, too.
-Got it.
Alright, I'll post
whichever one
gets the most
likes from all of us.
Because it's not a me post.
It's a we post.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Alright, are you ready?
Alright.
The first post is...
Yeah, enjoy.
-Enjoy.
-Yeah.
Hey, you'll love it.
I did
I mean, you will, you will.
-Those are real good.
-Alright, the votes are in.
Let's see the results.
Up at 136.
Alright.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Alright,
let's go to this next one.
This next one says...
[ Laughter ]
Hmm. Ooh.
-Ooh.
-Ooh, ooh, hi.
Candelabras.
-Ooh, fancy.
Alright, let's see
the results here.
-Ooh.
Do not be our guest.
-Alright, yeah.
-Wow.
-Very honest audience.
Yeah, they go. No.
Thank you, no.
They could have
chose not to vote.
-Yeah, no.
-They chose to vote.
No.
No, but I love that.
Alright, here we go.
The next one says...
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, window units
are the above ground...
I'm afraid of those things.
-Yeah.
-I was afraid to -- I was afraid
to install those ones.
I was afraid they would
fall out the window.
Alright, let's see
the results right here.
Alright, not bad.
Alright.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Two below.
-I don't know.
I mean, these all -- they don't
necessarily get better.
I just want to remind you guys.
[ Laughter ]
Next up, this one says...
-They're like pointing
at things.
-Too small.
-Pointing at stuff.
Alright, let's see
the results here.
Come on.
-I like this one.
Whoa! My God.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow.
Oh, wow.
-Now you're being too nice.
Now you're being too nice.
-Gotta be be a record.
-[ Laughs ]
This last one says...
[ Laughter ]
[ Deep voice ] Hey, you know
where the screw--
[ Clears throat ]
You know where the wrenches are?
-Nope.
-You want to arm wrestle?
-[ Normal voice ] Alright,
let's see the results here.
No, we got it back.
There you go.
We have a winner.
It looks like it's this
right here.
There's always two people.
[ Bell dings ]
I'm going to post this
during the break.
If you happen to see it online,
give that WePost a repost.